elon's cousin sent an Urgent Message to
Twitter Engineers Monday morning we are
debugging an issue with engagement
across the platform he tagged everybody
on slack please can you help solve this
problem it's very high urgency here's
the problem Elon Musk tweet about the
Super Bowl got less engagement than Joe
Biden despite having more followers
Biden's tweet generated 29 million
impressions you guys musk however we did
a sport for the Eagles and it only got
9.1 million so he deleted the Tweet
because he was so embarrassed with the
low impression count yes so Elon flies
back angry about his low Impressions
back to the Bay Area to demand answers
from his team within a day Twitter users
opened the app to find musk's posts were
being pushed to the top of their
timeline a lot of people noticed that
it's because Twitter deployed a code to
automatically green light all of musk's
tweets meaning his post will bypass
Twitter's filters designed to show
people the best content the algorithm
now artificially boosts must tweets by a
factor of 1000